bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va
s'intéresser aux ordinateurs quantiques
alors les ordinateurs quantiques ça fait
déjà un moment qu'on en entend parler
mais il semblerait que depuis quelques
mois les choses se soient accélérées et
on pourrait bien être à l'aube d'une
nouvelle ère pour l'informatique
on va donc essayer de comprendre ce que
c'est un ordinateur quantique comment ça
marche
ce qu'on peut faire avec et puis si on a
bientôt une chance d'en avoir un chez
soi
[Musique]
avant de parler d'ordinateurs quantiques
on va juste prendre deux minutes pour
rappeler comment fonctionne un
ordinateur normal pas au niveau des
logiciels mais d'un point de vue
fondamental
vous savez certainement que dans ces
circuits un ordinateur manipulent
l'information sous forme binaire des 0
et des 1 alors à notre niveau on s'en
rend pas compte mais tous les nombres la
musique les images tout ce qui défile
sur votre écran c'est stocker quelque
part sous forme de 0 et de 1
l'avantagent du binaire c'est que c'est
facile a représenté du point de vue
électrique
vous prenez un fil électrique si le
courant passe et 1 1 s'il ne passe pas
c'est 1-0 et c'est ça qu'on appelle un
beat il existe plein d'autres manières
physique de réaliser des beats ça peut
être des trous dans une carte perforée
ou bien la magnétisation la surface d'un
disque dur mais bon dans un circuit
d'ordinateurs ce qu'on utilise c'est le
courant électrique alors à notre niveau
quand on fait faire quelque chose un
ordinateur il utilise des algorithmes
qui généralement prennent un certain
nombre de données en entrée et
fournissent des sorties et ça c'est le
cas que vous soyez en train de regarder
un film de surfer sur internet d'écrire
un texte vous de faire tourner une
simulation numérique et comme au niveau
des circuits ces données sont sous forme
binaire et bien un algorithme ça se
réduit finalement à une suite
d'instructions permettant de traiter et
manipuler des beats les briques de base
avec lesquels on peut manipuler
l'information sous forme binaire c'est
ce qu'on appelle les portes logiques
il s'agit des opérations élémentaires
qui permettent d'agir sur les beats la
plus simple c'est la porte dite note
c'est la négation
c'est une porte qui va simplement
inversé la valeur d'un beat et on peut
représenter son action par un petit
tableau de ce genre autre exemple la
porte et cette porte prend deux buts en
entrée et en possède un an sorti le beat
de sortie voudra un uniquement si les
deux buts d'entrée sont à 1 et dans tous
les autres cas il sera zéro et le
tableau qui représente cette porte celle
suivre il existe plusieurs autres portes
logique élémentaire et je vais pas tout
vous les décrire mais ce qui est
important c'est que les opérations dont
on a l'habitude comme l'addition la
multiplication sont toutes faisable à
partir d'un assemblage de portes
logiques et avec seulement quelques
types de portes
on peut faire un ordinateur l'autre
chose extrêmement importante c'est que
ses portes logiques on sait les
fabriquer physiquement là je vous les ai
décrites de manière abstraite 1 mais on
sait les réaliser en utilisant des
composants électroniques et notamment
des transistors par exemple une porte
logique et sera réalisable avec deux
transistors de la manière suivante
et c'est pour ça qu'un micro processeurs
c'est essentiel
- un gros paquet de transistors câblée
entre eux qui permettent de réaliser des
portes logiques et de manipuler
l'information sous forme binaire
aujourd'hui les microprocesseurs peuvent
contenir jusqu'à plusieurs milliards de
transistors pour les plus puissants ça
c'était pour l'ordinateur normal passons
maintenant à l'ordinateur quantique
[Musique]
on l'a vu le job de base d'un ordinateur
c'est de manipuler des beats qui valent
0 ou 1
l'idée d'un ordinateur quantique c'est
d'utiliser des bits quantiques on
appelle ça des qubits les cubitt ce sont
des beats qui obéissent aux lois de la
mécanique quantique et notamment à un
principe fondamental le principe de
superposition
ce principe nous dit qu'un objet
quantique peut se trouver dans une
superposition de plusieurs états c'est à
dire qu'un cubitt n'est pas seulement
soit dans l'état zéro soit dans l'état
mais il peut être dans une superposition
des deux en quelque sorte dans les deux
états à la fois vous avez sans doute
déjà entendu parler du chat de
schrödinger qui serait à la fois mort et
vivant
en fait c'est pas vrai parce qu'en
pratique les chats quantique ça n'existe
pas un chat c'est bien trop gros mais si
on prend un objet suffisamment petit qui
peut être dans deux états il peut se
comporter comme un bit quantique et
obéir au principe de superposition
on va prendre un exemple vous savez
peut-être que les électrons possède ce
qu'on appelle un spin alors le spin
c'est une longue histoire mais
essentiellement ça conduit les électrons
à se comporter comme des petits aimants
qui quand on les met dans un champs
magnétiques peuvent être orientés soit
dans un sens ce soit dans l'autre et
bien un spin peut faire office de cubitt
il est dans un état dans l'autre mais il
peut être aussi dans une superposition
des deux en mécanique quantique on
utilise cette notation pour dire qu on
superpose des états alors quel est
l'intérêt d'avoir un cubitt plutôt qu'un
vite classique
imaginons vous ayez un calcul à faire et
qu'on vous demande de faire ce calcul
successivement en prenant comme donné
d'entrée le nombre 0 puis le nombre 1
avec un système classique vous allez
devoir faire le calcul deux fois une
fois avec zéro en entrée et une fois
avec 1
maintenant si on entre et vous avez un
cube it qui est une superposition de 0
et de 1
mais vous allez faire d'un seul coup les
deux calculs vous faites une seule
opération au lieu de deux alors est ce
que c'est ça un ordinateur quantique un
ordinateur qui fait deux opérations au
lieu d'une et qui calcule deux fois plus
vite
et ben non c'est pas si simple mais
c'est aussi beaucoup plus que ça
[Musique]
avec un ordinateur classique quand on
représente dénombre on n'utilise pas un
seul bit sinon on pourrait représenter
que 0 ou 1 mais on associe plusieurs
bits pour former ce qu'on appelle un
registre si vous utilisez un registre de
4 bits voici toutes les configurations
qu'il peut adopter 000 000 0 1 0 0 1 0 0
1 0 0 et c'est en tout il y à 16 états
possibles pour le registre qui
permettent donc de représenter des
nombres entre 0 et 15
maintenant imaginez un registre
quantique fait de 4q bits mais il peut
être dans une superposition de ces seize
états et c'est même encore plus que ça
parce qu'on peut mettre des coefficients
sur les états comme pour varier les
proportions de manière schématique être
dans 16 états à la fois ça permet de
faire c'est ce calcul en parallèle et si
on avait un registre de 8 bits
il pourrait dans une superposition de
deux cent cinquante six états et donc à
les deux cent cinquante fois plus vite
de manière générale si on prend un
registre de haine qubits il permet
d'aller deux puissances une fois plus
vite que l'équivalent classique
on estime aujourd'hui qu'avec un seul
registre d'une vingtaine de cubitt on
pourra atteindre la puissance d'un
ordinateur normal une quarantaine de
cubitt on serait au niveau du plus gros
ordinateurs qui existe et avec 100
cubitt bas je vous laisse faire le
calcul
un point important avoir en tête c'est
qu'un ordinateur quantique c'est pas
magique ça permet pas de faire des
choses qu'on ne pourrait pas faire avec
un ordinateur classique
ça va juste plus vite ça accélère les
calculs enfin certains calculs parce que
contrairement à ce que j'ai laissé
sous-entendre on ne peut pas tout
accéléré avec un ordinateur quantique et
on va pas les utiliser de la même
manière qu'on utilise un ordinateur
normal mais pour comprendre ça il faut
se plonger dans la manière dont on les
programme ces fameux ordinateur
quantique
je voulais dit avec un ordinateur normal
on effectue des opérations en manipulant
des beats à l'aide de portes logiques
qu'on s'est réalisée par exemple avec
des transistors
si maintenant vous utilisez des qubits
eh bien il va falloir changer de circuit
ça va plus marcher
il va falloir utiliser des portes
spécifiques les portes quantique les
portes quantique permettent de manipuler
des qubits et de faire avec eux des
opérations qu'on pourrait pas faire avec
des portes logiques normal juste pour
donner un exemple prenons la porte qu'on
appelle la porte de à dhamar alors elle
prend un cubi temps d'entrer et en donne
un os sortie et elle est telle que s'il
cubitt d'entrée n'est pas dans une super
position il faut par exemple un le cubi
de sortie lui sera dans une super
re position moitié-moitié 2-0 et 2-1 je
vous épargne les détails mais il existe
toute une zoologie de portes quantique
qui permettent de manipuler les cubitt
et qui prennent en entrée et en sortie
1-2-3 public voire beaucoup plus pour
les faire une maths on représente ses
portes quantique par des matrices
unitaire les matrices mais a quand même
un point essentiel pour comprendre le
fonctionnement d'un ordinateur quantique
et qui explique pourquoi on peut pas
faire n'importe quoi avec
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que un
ordinateur quantique c'est un peu comme
avoir un grand nombre d'ordinateurs dans
mots qui fonctionnerait en parallèle
mais en fait c'est pas tout à fait ça si
vous avez plein d'ordinateurs normaux
vous pouvez les faire travailler sur des
trucs qui n'ont rien à voir entre eux ou
leur faire faire chacun un calcul et
récupérer tous les résultats à la fin
avec un ordinateur quantique c'est pas
possible parce qu'à la fin vous ne
pourrez avoir de toutes façons qu'un
seul résultat cellier un principe
quantique qui s'appelle la réduction du
paquet d'onde
et qui dit que quand on a un état
superposé on peut pas le connaître en
entier
la seule chose qu'on puisse faire c'est
de le mesurer et dans ce cas là on le
réduit à une seule de ses composantes
donc même si un ordinateur quantique
peut faire plein de calculs en parallèle
à la fin il va vous donner qu'une seule
réponse donc ne pas l'utiliser pour
calculer plein de trucs et ramasser tous
les résultats
un ordinateur quantique sera donc
toujours moins polyvalent que son
équivalent en ordinateurs classiques et
c'est seulement sur certains types de
problèmes qui pourra vous faire
bénéficier de son pouvoir d'accélération
pour ça il faut des problèmes pour
lesquels on sache trouver un algorithme
spécifique un algorithme quantique fait
de portes quantique qui sera différent
de l'algorithme classique mais qui
permet d'exploiter cette idée de
parallélisme uniquement dans les calculs
intermédiaire mais en ne donnant qu'un
seul résultat à la fin prenons un
problème pour lequel ça marche pas mal
alors le problème à résoudre est le
suivant imaginez que vous ayez une
fonction f qui a un entier associe un
autre entier on peut leur présenter sous
forme d'un tableau et imaginons que je
vous demande par exemple de trouver
lanthier qui par la fonction donne le
nombre disons 42 algorithmes classiques
bas il n'y a pas trop le choix vous
regardez une par une les lignes du
tableau jusqu'à trouver le bon si vous
avez and line y dans le tableau il vous
faudra au maximum une étape avec un
ordinateur quantique
il existe un algorithme l'algorithme de
grover qui permet d'aller plus vite en
regardant des superpositions et qui
permet de trouver la solution en
seulement racines de haine étape
si vous avez un million de lignes dans
votre tableau l'algorithme quantique ne
prend que 1000 étapes au lieu de 1 me
il a donc mille fois plus vite c'est pas
mal non
mais garder en tête qu'il existe des
problèmes pour lesquels on ne connaît
pas voir il n'existe pas d'algorithmes
quantique qui soit plus rapide que
l'algorithme classique donc avoir un
ordinateur quantique c'est pas la
garantie absolue que tous les calculs se
trouve accélérée
mais voyons un exemple pour lequel
justement ça marche extrêmement bien et
qui est un peu l'archétype des problèmes
qu'on espère résoudre avec des
ordinateurs quantiques
il s'agit de la factorisation des
nombres entiers factoriser un nombre
s'est trouvé sa décomposition en un
produit de nombreux premiers
par exemple 70 c 2 x 5 x 7 48 1279 c'est
3 x 7 x 11 au carré x 10,9 alors ce
problème vous paraît peut-être pas très
compliqué il suffit de faire ça comme un
bourrin et de diviser successivement par
les nombres premiers 2 ou 3 5 etc
mais quand les facteurs premiers son
grand bain c'est plus dur par exemple 50
6153 à votre avis est-ce décompose
comment eybens et 233 fois 241 pas si
simple à trouver ce problème de
factorisation en nombres premiers il est
très important parce que c'est là dessus
que se basent un certain nombre
d'algorithmes de cryptographie comme par
exemple l'algorithme rsa qui est très
utilisé pour cracker un chiffrage rsa
bat sur le papier c'est assez simple il
suffit de trouver la décomposition au
facteur premier d'un nombre très grands
genres un nombre comme celui là alors en
théorie trouver la décomposition pose
pas vraiment de problème il suffit de
faire pleins pleins de division mais en
pratique si on voulait vraiment faire ce
calcul même avec l'ordinateur le plus
puissant du monde
eh bien ça prendrait un temps démentiel
et c'est ça qui protège la sécurité des
communications qui sont chiffrés avec un
algorithme de type rsa pour quantifier
le temps et les ressources mémoire dont
a besoin un algorithme pour faire un
calcul on parle de sa complexité
et évidemment ça va dépendre de la
taille des données d'entrée si vous
prenez un très grand nombre à factoriser
ça va prendre plus de temps que si le
nombre était petit
ce que vous voyez ici c'est une mesure
de la complexité du meilleur algorithme
dont on dispose pour factoriser un
nombre s'est représenté en échelle
logarithmique et vous voyez que ça
augmente très vite quand le nombre à
factoriser devient important en 1994
alors que l'ordinateur quantique n'était
toujours qu'une idée sur le papier un
chercheurs des bell labs peter shore a
trouvé un algorithme quantique qui
permet de faire de la factorisation en
nombres premiers
alors cet algorithme je vais pas vous le
décrire en détail mais évidemment il se
base sur un assemblage de portes
quantique et ce qui est spectaculaire
c'est que sa complexité
et bien inférieure à celle du meilleur
algorithme classiques dont on dispose
vous en voyez ici une illustration et
plus le nombre de départs et grands n'a
plus l'avantagent de l'algorithme
quantique sera notable on dit qu'il est
exponentiellement meilleur cet
algorithme qu'on appelle l'algorithme de
shore a été un petit coup de tonnerre
parce que sur le papier il permet de
casser la sécurité de toutes les
communications chiffrées par rsa enfin
sur le papier on va voir comment ça se
passe en pratique
[Musique]
tout ce que je vous ai décrit jusqu'ici
est assez théorique je vous ai parlé de
cubitt de portes quantique d'algorithmes
quantique mais je vous ai pas dit
comment on allait faire concrètement
pour faire un ordinateur classique on
l'a vu on utilise du courant électrique
pour faire des beats et soit le courant
passe soit ils passent pas mais comment
on fait en pratique pour faire un cubi
tu es bien vous faut un système qui
puisse être dans deux états mais qui
soit suffisamment petit pour obéir aux
lois de la mécanique quantique et que
donc on puisse mettre dans un état
superposé
il existe différentes manières de faire
ça on peut utiliser par exemple le spin
des électrons ou d'un noyau atomique
la polarisation d'un photon ou bien
certains circuits supraconducteurs tous
ces objets sont susceptibles de former
des qubits mais ce qui est compliqué
c'est d'une part d'arriver en associés
suffisamment pour former un registre
quantique assez grand mais surtout de
les maintenir
isolée du monde extérieur pour qu'il
soit stable et restent dans leurs états
superposés du moins suffisamment
longtemps pour qu'on puisse faire le
calcul dont on a envie et ça c'est pas
facile alors petite anecdote personnelle
quand j'ai commencé ma thèse
j'étais dans un institut de physique
théorique au canada qui est maintenant
devenu un des hauts lieux de
l'informatique quantique et en 2002 tous
les chercheurs du domaine était en
effervescence parce que pour la première
fois un groupe de recherche dans le
monde avait réussi à faire tourner
l'algorithme de shore sur un ordinateur
quantique
l'exploit a eu lieu dans les labos dit
bm en californie leur ordinateur
quantique comportait sept cubitt et
grâce à ça il avait réussi à factoriser
le nombre 15
c'est à dire qu'ils avaient réussi à
calculer que 15 c'est trois fois 5 15
égal 3 x 5 mais ils l'ont trouvée avec
un ordinateur quantique et à partir de
ce moment là ça a été la course pour
savoir qui fabriquerait l'ordinateur
quantique le plus gros et le plus
puissant en 2005 le record est passé à 8
bits et en 2006 12 cubitt mais le moment
où on a commencé à entendre vraiment
parler tout ça au delà des labos de
recherche
c'est en 2011 quand la société
canadienne dit wade a annoncé le
lancement sur le marché du premier
ordinateur quantique un ordinateur
quantique qu'on pouvait acheter
alors je vais pas vous refaire toute
l'histoire mais il faut savoir qu'il ya
eu pas mal de controverses pour savoir
si dit wade avait véritablement
fabriquer un ordinateur quantique ou pas
il ya beaucoup de spécialistes qui
pensent que non et en tout cas que sa
rapidité était pas du tout ce qu'on
attendait d'un véritable ordinateur
quantique et il faut aussi savoir que
cet ordinateur était pas universel il
permettait seulement de résoudre un type
de problème bien particulier malgré tout
il ya quelques entreprises qui en
avaient les moyens qu'ils ont décidé de
l'acheter pour l'étudier en parallèle de
sa en 2000
14 on a appris suite aux révélations des
douars snowdon que la haine et c'est l'
agence nationale de sécurité américaines
financé à hauteur de 80 millions de
dollars
un programme de recherche son ordinateur
quantique répondant au doux nom de
pénétrer eating rap target pénétrer les
cibles difficiles avec notamment un
projet sobrement appelée owning de
n'être posséder le réseau tout un
programme
mais c'est surtout ces derniers mois que
l'excitation autour des ordinateurs
quantiques a repris de plus belle toutes
les grosses boîtes un google microsoft
ibm ainsi qu'un certain nombre de start
up issue de la boue universitaires se
sont lancés dans la course et construire
des ordinateurs quantiques basé sur
différentes technologies
toutes ces entreprises courent notamment
après un objectif psychologique qu'on
appelle la suprématie quantique la
suprématie quantique ça désigne le jour
où pour la première fois on arrivera à
résoudre avec un ordinateur quantique
quelque chose qu'on n'arrive pas à
résoudre avec un ordinateur classique et
jusqu'ici ça n'a pas encore été le cas à
part la factorisation en nombres
premiers il existe plein de problèmes
qu'on pense pouvoir résoudre de manière
plus rapide à l'aide d'algorithmes
quantique qui tournerait sur un
ordinateur quantique comme par exemple
des simulations numériques qui
permettrait de développer de nouveaux
médicaments ou de mieux comprendre le
comportement de la matière au niveau
quantique
ouais on utiliserait un ordinateur
quantique pour résoudre des problèmes de
mécanique quantique c'est pas beau ça
alors on n'en est pas encore là mais à
la vitesse où vont les choses il est
bien possible que la suprématie
quantique soit atteinte en 2017
mais par qui en premier mais les paris
sont ouverts merci d'avoir suivi la
vidéo comme d'hab lié pas de vous
abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait à
cliquer sur la cloche si vous êtes déjà
abonné vous pouvez me suivre sur
facebook et twitter pour avoir les
actifs de la chaîne et vous pouvez aussi
dire surtout dit merci à bientôt
[Musique]